incredible video coming out of arizona
an out of control fire burning northeast
of flagstaff this has been named the
tunnel fire and listen to this this
thing tripled in size last night due to
no small part to those high winds we've
been seeing also just learn zero
containment still at this hour and of
course
if you're getting wildfires in april
just gonna say it's so early
not june it's april right that tells you
what kind of season we've been having it
seems like even i don't know maybe over
the past decade the seasons continue to
grow on both ends that's exactly it and
we talked about this too before i'm now
planning my vacations around these
wildfires because they're going to
happen every summer now no doubt they're
going to happen every summer there's no
doubt about it's a shame so uh we have
to watch for that tomorrow because we do
have a high uh we do have a fire weather
warning for tomorrow to do the elevated
fire danger we got low humidity tomorrow
and strong winds not a good combination
for tomorrow right now the winds are
breezy but not as strong as what we're
going to see for your thursday 84 our
official high for the day today cooler
than yesterday but still five above
average
61 was our morning start so here are
current temperatures outside we start
off and those of you in spring valley
that are watching us right now 82
degrees 83 centennial hills 81 sky
canyon 83 for north las vegas the east
side coming in 86 along with whitney
ranch in green valley 81 mountains edge
and rhodes ranch and henderson you're
coming to 85 southern highlands 83 at
this hour meanwhile elsewhere 84 up in
mesquite in northeast clark good evening
to all of you 95 for death valley and
currently 80 right now for uh prop over
the hump at this hour so that system off
the coast pinwheeling the showers right
now into the pacific northwest even
seeing some showers encroaching into the
bay area we remain dry right now but as
this moves on shore the sierras will
swallow up most of that rain
but as you can see here from this future
cast i put what we call the isobars here
anytime these isobars are close together
it shows you how strong the winds are
going to get and this is taking aim
again at the west coast and also giving
us slight chances for showers when
friday mountain snow also possible with
this we hope so but look at this chances
for showers on friday that's around noon
time could see it also in the afternoon
before it starts to slowly diminish and
go away by friday night temperature
trend also shows the thing we can see
with that system too is a huge
temperature drop look at thursday 82
friday down to 70 degrees so your
forecast overnight 60 degrees by morning
breezy and cool tonight and that goes
tomorrow morning as well tomorrow 82 are
high windy and dusty again we could see
a windy dust advisory issued for
tomorrow and could see a wind advisory
issued for the valley as well we'll wait
and see if that happens our normal is 80
degrees so we'll be just slightly above
normal for this time of the year here is
your eight day forecast i'll step out of
the way here and show you that big
temperature dump we talked about chances
for showers but also a chances for
isolated thunderstorms too there's
enough
instability that we'll see that day and
then the weekend looking pretty good of
course
sunday tonight's game looking good if
you're headed to that hopefully we get
the big w for that we need a w big big
big time they need all w's yeah
yes